TALKING ABOUT THAT COULD BE A
NEW MASSIVE DEVELOPMENT.
HERE NOW WITH MORE ON HIS BIG
RELEASE, HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE RANKING MEMBER DOUG
COLLINS.
THANK YOU, WE WOULDN'T KNOW SO
MUCH THAT WE KNOW BUT FOR YOUR
COURAGE TO RELEASE THESE
CLOSED-DOOR TESTIMONY DOCUMENTS.
WHAT DID YOU TAKE OUT OF
YESTERDAY, ABOUT LORETTA LYNCH
AND SO MUCH MORE?
>> WELL, THANKS, SEAN.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT JOHN
TALKED ABOUT IS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE TURNING BECAUSE
THEY'RE SEEING THE TRUTH,
THEY'RE SEEING THE TESTIMONIES
THAT THE INVESTIGATORS DID, YOU
SAW IT WITH MY COLLEAGUES,
RADCLIFF, JORDAN, MEADOWS,
OTHER.
WHAT THEY FOUND OUT, THERE WAS A
CONFLICT, WHAT THEY WERE FINDING
OUT, THERE IS A COVERUP, THEY
KNEW IF IT WAS EVER UNCOVERED
THAT THERE WOULD BE TROUBLE.
LYNCH, WE KNEW, IT WAS BASICALLY
WE'VE SEEN THE INCOMPETENT SHE
SHOWED AS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
NOW WE'RE SEEING THEM TURNING ON
JIM COMEY, WHO, HIS LITTLE RUN
AS CAPTAIN AMERICA IS COMING TO
AN END.
HE IS NOT WHAT HE HAS PORTRAYED
HIMSELF TO BE, THERE'S GOING TO
BE ANSWERING FOR THAT BASED ON
THE TRANSCRIPTS.
THERE'S CONTRADICTIONS AT EVERY
TURN.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
JOHN SOLOMON'S REPORT?
BRUCE ORR WARNING, WE KNOW THIS
WOMAN TEN DAYS BEFORE THE FIRST
FISA APPLICATION WARNED ALL OF
THESE UPPER ECHELON, AGAIN, NOT
RANK AND FILE, NOT THE 99%, VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND THEY WERE WARNED IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS, THEY HAD
PROBABLY 10 TIMES THE AMOUNT OF
EVIDENCE THAT WAS EXCULPATORY,
INCLUDING TRANSCRIPTS WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR ABOUT AS JOHN SAID
IN THE NEXT WEEK OR SO, WITHIN
THE NEXT WEEK.
AND THEY NEVER LISTENED TO IT Y?
>> BECAUSE IT WAS WHAT THEY, I
THINK THEY HAD A PATTERN ALL THE
TIME.
THIS IS A RUPTCA BAL OF THE TOP
LEADER -- A KOR RUN CABAL,
DIDN'T LIKE CANDIDATE TRUMP,
DIDN'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEY WERE
COVERING FOR THEMSELVES.
THEY HAD WHAT THEY BELIEVED WAS
AN INSURANCE POLICY, THEY
BELIEVED IT WAS GOING TO BE THE
INVESTIGATION THAT WOULD SHOW
THERE WAS A PROBLEM.
WHAT IS DISTURBING HERE, THEY
KNEW THAT THEY HAD A PROBLEM
WITH THESE INFORMATION THEY WERE
GETTING FROM STEELE AND THE
DOSSIER.
YET THEY WENT WITH IT AS YOU
SAID, COMEY VERIFIED THIS, JUST
A FEW MONTHS LATER, SAID IT WAS
SALACIOUS.
WE HAVE THAT TODAY, THAT'S THE
THING THAT'S INTERESTING.
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN VERIFIED.
>> Sean: THEY'VE BEEN DEBUNKED.
NOW LOOK AT THIS, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL UNDER OBAMA, LYNCH,
BASICALLY ACCUSING THE FBI
DIRECTOR AT THE TIME OF PERJURY.
CONGRESSMAN, THIS IS SO